Just as map reduce provides a simple and intuitive programming model
for the domain expert to develop big data applications, PTS provides
a simple programming model for the domain expert to develop live
stream analysis applications. Time-based distributed data
structures for streams, automatic data management,
transparent stream persistence. These are then
unique features of the PTS programming model
that facilitates live stream analysis. I invite you to read the paper in its
entirety to understand the many systems
challenges that are identified and solved by
PTS in providing this programming model. This
completes our discussion in this course on
the topic of real-time and multimedia.